okay team building on this side of the
room Stanley Phyllis Jim Ted Elroy and
this side of the room Pam Meredith
Phyllis Creed
you never called a meeting
one of the hardest parts about making
resolutions is keeping them in fact most
resolutions are abandoned by February or
sooner yeah it's not a joke but that's
okay because it's not about being
perfect it's about trying in fact why
don't we go around and confess some of
the ways that we've already fudged on
our resolutions well I said that I would
eat more vegetables and I haven't yet
but it's okay I still have time since
last year I ate none okay well my
confession is that today I had a sip of
coffee but that's fine is it yes because
with all of your support by this time
next year maybe I'll be down to one
glass of iced tea a week next year I
mean what is the point what is the point
of that I made a resolution to floss and
I did it 1201 January 1st bam blood
everywhere not all of us are Michael
freaking Scott what is wrong with you
people can't you stick to anything Erin
I want you to go to the kitchen and get
me some vegetables great you say you
want to do a cartwheel nothing's
stopping you come on old man do a
cartwheel well I can't I don't know how
you're just gonna somersault around for
the rest of your life and you know
what's going to be on your Tombstone
loser my tombstone's already made thank
you just do a cartwheel this is all I
can find
eat it you don't have to do that Kevin I
don't know I'm glad this is happening
thank you Michael
why are you eating stem first this is a
new food for me how well should I eat it
the other way
can I get some cheese whiz or
hollandaise no no cheese whiz no
hollonnaise no chocolate sauce just eat
it come on here comes the airplane there
you go open open into the hanger there
you go yep eat it put it in your mouth
and just eat it I don't care whether you
hate it you said you do it all right
Michael eat it eat it you're killing him
Michael all right all right all right
I ate some fluffy Park can I be Brown
let me see if you swallowed it open your
mouth
under your tongue
oh God
I promise Dwight couldn't get it up for
Nelly no no no no no no it's not me I'm
gonna prove it right here and now
stop that stop it
fine it was me I couldn't I had a
problem with it Aaron last night happy
I had a lot on my mind last night and I
didn't perform
okay happens to plenty of guys
it's usually not followed by a giant
workplace discussion and an interview
every guy in this room has been touched
by this Affliction tuna D dog
um
um I have other issues I'm terrible at
math
overweight you you're in great shape a
lot better shape than I am tell you what
it seems Andy is the only one with this
problem fascinating fascinating I don't
really see what the problem is Aaron
doesn't even like sex remember you said
it feels like getting tackled by
skeleton jumbo come on help me out any
problems with little jumbo tip top shape
oh Stanley Lou
Creed you are a thousand years old I
haven't heard any complaints wouldn't
care if I did okay so so I I I I think
maybe we've experienced it what happened
that a couple of times a couple of times
Jim maybe you could tell us about one of
those times yeah yeah get it out there
um I don't
uh yes that time that it was very late
uh we had had sex so many times already
I was exhausted I could barely see I was
very drunk if it makes you feel any
better I never had an orgasm until I was
42 and then when I did it lasted till I
was 44. 43 was
I got nothing done
I've read and I don't know anything
about this personally but they say
prostate stimulation can help
this is just um This American Life I
think that's absolutely the case I know
right you know my rectal Electro
ejaculator is rated for bovine use only
but I could let you rent it
Andy why don't you tell us about the
best erection of your life or does
anyone else have any remarkable
erections
on HR have some rules against talking
about this kind of stuff marinates are
it's a joke I can't do anything about
anything you know what I'm going to
raise the stakes
you don't we don't I want you to watch
this
and I want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image
then I want you people to remember for a
long time to come whenever you come into
the office I want you to think about
this
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
ah
oh I did it
see
I'm still here
we're all still here
oh come on Dwight come on man thank you
all for meeting on such short notice yes
yes Michael Scott Dunder Mifflin what is
the purpose of this meeting seeing as
it's Valentine's Day I felt it would be
apropos to have a little refresher
course on romance in the workplace
perfect yes it is quite apropriate Carry
On First Things First an office romance
is permissible not something you'd
expect to hear from corporate well guess
what saber is 100 tolerant of office
romances speaking of Gabe I don't see
Aaron at this meeting uh I also don't
see Andy oh
boom face I get it Andy's slamming my
girlfriend very funny what I do not
approve of however is public displays of
affection or pdas pdas are totally
Superfluous to a happy healthy office
Romance
a perfect example look at Jim and Pam
yeah
yeah what us they don't touch they don't
kiss you would hardly even know that
they were husband and wife did it yeah
love it keep it going okay so pdas
that's going to include behaviors such
as hugging kissing uh booby honking yeah
booby hugging sure but honking butt
honking yep all the hunkings the woman
you start in a Crouch position and you
lose so basically there's no precise
definition but you know it when you see
it
oh
are you guys listening to this
what are you talking about me and Holly
yeah
maybe you find your own chair
I would not
seal the bread and I would not let my
family go hungry okay but we should get
back to business have any of you ever
faced any ethical dilemmas in the
workplace
anybody this is a chance for you to say
something without any repercussions
Stanley Oscar come on pass
I will go first
when I discovered YouTube I didn't work
for five days I did nothing I viewed
Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain
about a thousand times what was the
Dilemma
to tell you or not
and I'm glad I did I feel very very good
cathartic I promise you that you were
not going to get into trouble you can
say anything you want with total and
complete immunity
come on anybody let it fly once once in
a while I'll take a long lunch a siesta
Time Thief Time Thief fire him go ahead
you've really never stolen any company
time never you are a thief of Joy
anybody else yeah sometimes I download
pirated music onto my work computer who
hasn't good good what else no I'd like
to hear more about that I once reported
Oscar to the ins
turns out he's clean but I'm glad I did
it
well let's keep this party moving on
I'll go
have you guys ever met Bruce Myers the
Scranton rep for Hammer Mill
well for the past six years I've been
sleeping with him in exchange for
discounts on our supplies and Outback
Steakhouse gift certificates jackpot
Meredith that is
serious
I mean not only is that a conflict of
interest but there's also an exchange of
goods
exchange of stake
have you ever had sirloin steak honey
that's crazy that's a crazy talk
Meredith
the marinators sleeping with suppliers
oh
wow what time we got
that's a good place to end it